hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast on the topic of
optimizing animal study designs today's
presentation is titled critical
appraisal of animal studies my name is
Juliana and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots for more
information please visit lab roots com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
could submit questions by typing them
into the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button on the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit a problem
through the green Q&A button on the
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. chiffon ban dr.
Braun has worked in the field of
laboratory animal medicine for 15 years
his accomplishment including venting a
freezing protocol for non-human primate
embryonic stem cells that increases stem
cell survival rate from five percent
over ninety percent he additionally
contributed to the development of one of
the first canine embryonic stem cell
lines he has since pioneered new
territory by developing and improving
online surgical training in the
laboratory animal medicine field dr.
Brown currently works as the head of
innovative animal technologies and
training at Novartis Institute for
biomedical research he serves as an
adjunct assistant professor at the Wake
Forest School of Medicine the editor in
chief of cervical at seven newsletter
and directed at large for the Academy of
surgical research he is additionally on
the board of directors for Americans for
medical progress in an editorial board
member for the Journal of veterinary
science and technology dr. bond earned
his doctorate in veterinary medicine
from the university of pennsylvania in
2002 he is currently working on the
refinement and development of
gastrointestinal and Larry school
big rodent reproductive procedures as
well as the development and
implementation of surgical competency
assessment programs I will now turn it
over to dr. Bauer on first presentation
well thank you so much for this worthy
introduction and i would like to also
thank all of the participants joining us
this late i know for some of you guys
it's still early afternoon something
because it's at night but we really
appreciate our at least I really
appreciate you guys being here so like
during the introduction we're going to
talk about really how to bring a
surgical model in house and we're really
going to concentrate mainly on Rudin's
however you can apply all of this into
larger animals as well one of the things
i wanted to mention it for example this
morning reading in a fortune magazine
there was an article addressing ripping
up corporate speed and they're talking
about in there about all of the
different resources technology that's
available to us and when they're being
implemented the speed at which the
decisions are being made these various
companies has been slowing down so for
example hurry hiring you know 2010 it
was took about forty two days and now it
takes about sixty-five days so I think
it kind of applies to this process
because or some of the other processes
that we implement in Lebanon medicine
then when you apply new processes it can
be frustrating it certainly can increase
the amount of time that we spend on it
however over time we end up just like in
this article they end up with better
candidates the common board so it
decreases the rate of nutrition the rate
of people quitting
and all the other challenges the
potential come with but there's not a
good fit between employer and employee
so it's the same thing and the process
that we're going to talk about today I
think initially might be even a little
bit overwhelming and when we implemented
it it took a little bit actually quite a
bit longer but over time we became used
to it and now it's very efficient but
what's more important it really provides
us with the right surgical models so
with that any further ado when I go to
that next slide and first what you
really have to make a decision as do you
need the surgical model is it really
important or is it something just nice
to have so in this scenario we're going
to assume that you really need this
model this is part of a PhD project that
can move forward without it or it's the
next blockbuster that depends on it so
there's really two ways that models are
being brought it so why is the
conventional way which includes for
example a postdoctoral student who needs
to implement the model in order for the
project to move forward so she or he end
up reading various references
publications they may look at some of
the videos they're available on the
internet or in another way for example
you have a surgeon that's at the
facility and even though they did not
perform a specific procedure that you
need they have enormous amount of
experience and other surgical procedures
so the end up doing similar thing
looking at references that are available
but they might look at some of the video
content that's out there so most of the
cases and bringing your models fit in
between those two
and I think there's few challenges with
that one some of the videos are
available internet very often they're
pretty short and their time limits for
them so they might be good for basic
procedures like implementing a
subcutaneous pump or you know something
basic that they see in a few minutes or
so during surgery but if you're talking
about more complex procedures like GI
procedures or neurologic procedures
tonometry procedures very often
disabilities are quite edited so you
can't really get a good idea of how the
whole procedure moves forward the other
aspect for references is looking at the
publication's very rarely have a hoop
procedure described in the publication
and also instrumentation equipment very
often doesn't address complications that
occurred and how the procedure was
developed so when we looked at their
process we decided that there are some
points where we can refine it so what
I'm going to talk to you guys today
about is in the end what we ended up
with and how the process works so here
are just the various steps and we're
going to go through each one of them but
you need to look at the collection of
references need to review the references
summarize references then we're going to
talk about protocol development facility
considerations of course you also need
to consider equipment and supplies that
are available to you we're really going
to touch up on the test subject in the
animal that's part of the procedure and
you definitely need to look at obviously
the surgeon then we're going to discuss
financial considerations and we're going
to give you some of the examples what
the different calls to come along there
might be a good start for you guys if
you want to implement this process
talking about timeline considerations
and then also you you know how do we
decide if it's going to be in-house or
going to outsource the spirt that this
this project the other steps is also
really piloting the surgical procedure
which is very important and very well
then at least initially we ended up
missing that step and I think most
people very often do as well so then
we're going to talk about you know how
do you assess the procedure that's being
performed in house and the last two
steps include protocol refinement and
then piloting that surgical procedure so
collecting references we have a lot of
different resources so here's just a few
examples and that we end up utilizing
and we go through really each and one
and very often in each one of these
databases we end up locating a one or
two articles if not more they're
appropriate for us and when we look for
references we really look for anything
that mentions the procedure they were
interested in the other aspect is the 3
R's which obviously we have to pay
attention to for a lot of different
reasons and so here are some of the list
the or I guess databases or websites
that we utilize for that process and
this PDF of this presentation is
available to you so you can have that as
a reference if you like to use or check
out some of these websites so these days
social media is huge we're all in one
way or another work with it one
obviously you're here at leopards would
you have a network for I thing as some
of the people per facebook for
scientists um this is one of the
resources that we certainly realize that
we ask questions and we receive feedback
but then also some of the other groups
that are in here so unlinked it there
are various groups like laboratory
animal science group accounting a
surgical research American Association
for laboratory
scientists and also in the PDF the
urology we have links for these for
these groups but the way we utilize
these is we ask questions their post
questions and you can get feedback from
the experts in those areas because again
very often folks who are part of these
specific groups have similar interest in
surgery so we're going to talk about the
collection of references but before I
move forward they also would like to
hold the audience so if you could answer
this question d perform surgeries and
rodents this will give me a little bit
of a better idea of who is an audience
and get my presentation a little bit
more towards the audience
so about 60 Elmo 64% perform rodent
surgery and 20 at about 30 I guess it
would be 35 they do not so now there's
one more question if you mind answering
and do you perform surgeries and species
other than romance so here we have a
little bit more even split 50 almost
forty-eight percent say yes you do okay
fantastic that gives me a little better
idea with the audiences so here are the
links that i mentioned that you would
see on the PDF that's available for this
presentation so collecting references
what we also found that emailing that
authors of the references that we or
manuscripts or papers that we have read
and during a process over several years
we find there really the second author
of the paper usually the person who
perform the procedure and it's also very
open to talk with us and provide us with
some information the potentially might
not be in the manuscripts we also found
that it takes about three emails to do
that and very often when we end up
talking to the authors they mention here
they didn't see the email or they
skipped it or whatever the reason is but
in most cases they're pretty open about
discussing and providing it to shore
information the other part what we also
do is end up funding up with or setting
up the phone call a teleconference with
that person and you really find out a
lot more information that you can get
one especially from the reference but
even from the email interaction because
you can ask for his post up questions so
those are very helpful and we over the
years average or about eighty-five
percent of different procedures that we
have implemented and one of the things i
can't stress enough you really need to
take detailed notes for me at least if I
don't write it down and forget so even
if i think i am going to remember this
very often i do not and i think that's
the case for a lot of folks so really
make sure you take detailed notes when
you have these conversations so now when
you have collected their references you
need to review them so what we look at
is just do the references and mention
aseptic technique i'm at some of the
basics of the procedure we also try to
find out who the surgeon is is this
someone with a lot of experience no
experience and also what country the
reference the publication is from
because very often for example not often
but in a few cases are some of them
drugs that are available for example
europe are not available in united
states or vice versa so then we also
look at the survivability so mortality
and morbidity I that's something that's
really important and when we found that
through the conversations and the email
communications we find that what's
sometimes in the publications to get
through those numbers very often you
know it took somebody several months to
develop death model which is really
important for us
especially when we're starting out the
model in house and then what's the
length of the study so for example if
you perform a procedure that their study
was only two weeks and have a hundred
percent survivability if your study is
supposed to be six months you have to
take that into consideration because you
might see different numbers that they do
so the next step is summarizing these
references and here I cannot stress
enough you really need to put as much
detail into that process into this step
of the process as you can because this
will make their following steps
significantly easier for you when you
implement this so now we're going to
talk about protocol development so
obviously you need to look at the
surgical procedure from all the
different descriptions of the
conversations that you had you need to
look at the animal information and
consider are you going to be working
with the same species hopefully you are
so she could like these references but
very often it's also useful there for
example if you're looking at let's say
gastric bypass and a dog or a nonhuman
primate reviewing the literature even
interesting about doing a procedure and
rodents so you need to look at the basic
aspects of your animal information of
your patients a species strain age
gender housing also consider the
enrichment and the nutrition and we'll
talk about that a little bit more in a
few slides you also have to look at
whatever facilities would be required
for the protocol you also have to look
at the equipment and the supplies that
will utilize and again especially some
miscellaneous supplies and that's where
you get most of their information when
you have the teleconferences with the
folks who have performed these
procedures in the past and what's really
important to develop a checklist this
will make your life significantly easier
when you have that someone asks
you for you know what you need you can
go through that but really when that's
important when you actually get to the
point where you're going to be doing a
procedure to make sure that process
running efficiently do you have this
procedure is running efficiently so you
have all that items that are necessary
for the specific surgery so now let's
look up at the review process so for us
when the protocol is developed and that
was developed by one or two surgeons
then it's being reviewed by additional
surgeons who most will be nice if they
have experience in the same species it's
also really good to get feedback from
experience surgical technicians because
they give you a slightly different view
and scientists I think it's really
important to involve the scientists for
whom the project or the surgery and the
animal is going to be for because for
them again this is like a tool they're
going to utilize so you wanna make sure
that what you're deciding to do it
really also make sense for them as well
so it's really important to get their
feedback during this process so now
let's talk about facilities um so as you
think about performing those procedures
even if you do have surgical facilities
for even rooted facilities for example
so you perform basic surgical procedure
your facility maybe this is a more
complex procedure so their requirements
that are going to be slightly different
or sometimes quite a bit different so
you need to look at the macro
environment which is the surgical suite
and in large animals even if it's
obviously the various areas and see if
it's available for you to perform those
procedures and then looking at the micro
environment so especially for rodent
surgery so you're looking at the
surgical
area is it large enough for all of the
equipment that you're going to need so
for example if you're performing
telemetry you know bring your two
software and computers into the room so
you can check if the telemetry is
working during the surgical procedure or
near the end and immediately afterwards
and as we know very often rotate surgery
Suites are pretty tight at least in my
experience so it's really important to
address that before you jump into this
project so when you consider the
supplies and equipment you need to
develop a wish list so everything that
someone has recommended added to the
list look at the protocol your
experience and your colleagues
experiences but in the end really you
also have to look at the reality so for
example surgical microsurgical
instrumentation can be pretty expensive
you know eight to twelve thirteen
fourteen fourteen hundred dollars apiece
so if you need ten new instruments
that's a pretty significant investment
and so are you able to invest in those
packages or are there other things that
you could potentially utilize so again
it's one of those aspects where you have
to consider do I need these this
equipment or the discrimination or is it
kind of a nice to have so we already
talked about the test subject but when
you're considering and selecting it
these are all of the aspects they have
to consider you know the species is
there is it the right species or
potentially are you moving forward with
the species because it has been and
described in references so for example a
lot of procedures have been performed in
rats because they're larger so it's
slightly easier to perform as procedures
but maybe a better model or a transgenic
model t is only available in in mice and
again this is the process in which
having
scientists participate is really
important and then looking at the
background estrella gender & age weight
size and also looking at the references
the procedures they have been already
performed that you talked to folks
should perform them are you going to be
performing in the same species in the
same sex of the animal all those things
have to be considered because they might
have a pretty significant impact on the
outcome of the surgical procedures so
one of the examples in outbred animals
for gastric bypass the survivability is
100 almost a hundred percent but if you
go into transgenic model some of the
diabetic models they can decrease by a
couple percent so just setting up your
expectations will knowing this
information that will make that process
a little bit easier the other part
little bit mention that but are you
going with the appropriate model or are
you going the easiest model and
sometimes so we have find it as a
surgeon there's some species or specific
and breeds that i would like to
entertaining mice or rats that i would
like to work with but maybe they're not
the best model for the scientists or for
this project so again you need to
consider that I'm as well surgical
consideration and selection this process
is very important especially when it
comes to rodents because very often
folks who perform road in surgery do not
have surgical or medical background or
veterinary background however they are
very quite a few to very excellent
surgeons to do that but again if you
have it for example a postdoc that's
jumping into performing surgery and they
have never performed surgery you have to
consider you know how is it he or she is
going to be trained what's the time
frame from the training do we have
personnel available with the resources
to provide the type of training
and then when you have worked with
experienced surgeons need to look at the
competency and proficiency so also
looking at internal personnel so we kind
of talked about on the previous slide so
let me go back to that you know you have
things in experienced surgeon our
experienced surgeon but if you decide to
go with an external surgery at
potentials going to come to your
facility well we find that develop will
have developed a question here and that
we utilize for that and in that question
here we ask the background the specialty
of the surgeon how did they learn the
procedure from whom did they learn the
procedure how many times they performed
a procedure and also when was the last
time that they perform this procedure so
if they have done is two or three years
ago potentially the one the first couple
animals might be or should be utilized
for the pilot before you jump into the
actual endlessly going to use on your
project then also asking about the
success rate so mortality morbidity but
then also the lunge a divot II of that
project I'm like I mentioned before so
is your project going to be six months
and their experience with the model is
two or three weeks and also asking for
references I know that's not always
feasible especially in the industry they
can't just call up your you know provide
the references but if they are available
we highly recommend reaching out to them
and confirming or finding out a little
bit more information about the surgeon
one of the things that we find in
providing a question here allows the
surgeon on their own time to fill it out
think about it and provide us with the
answer versus having a TC or an
in-person conversation where it might be
a little bit intimidating so now we're
going to talk about the fun stuff that
financial considerations so here I want
to go through with you at the table that
we have on the left hand side
you're going to see the process then a
personnel that we involved in the
process and obviously for your facility
organization might be slightly different
then also the time that's required to
complete the specific process then we
have the hourly wage and for that we end
up utilizing which against you on the
bottom there on the left-hand side the
2014 laboratory animal facility
compensation survey so obviously that
might be a slightly different depending
where you live and again this is for
United States and then on the right-hand
side the less column is going to be the
subtotal for that specific process
alright so let's go to that next slide
so the first step was collection of
references research technicians assist
us with that on average it takes
thirteen point seven hours the hourly
wage twenty-three point six dollars so
heads up to about that about butt heads
up 23 23 so before I go to the next step
in the process something to consider is
also the references that you will need
so here we have if you're looking at
individual articles there the cost
varies between 25 to $45 per article
Aaron's 32.5 so on average for us we
have used about 47 articles so if you
end up paying for that that's a little
bit over fifty hundred dollars if you're
looking at individual journals and
subscriptions and this is again on the
bottom here you can see from elsevier
website so that might differ also
depending where you are but the cost is
between 144 to little bits under forty
five hundred dollars so the average cost
we took 86 862 dollars per journal so
using 14 journals I get on average
that's what works
for us that's a little bit over twelve
thousand dollars and I'm well aware of
that obviously universities and very
similar companies large companies have
access to these databases but very often
what's for us what we found especially
looking at the older articles and this
is something that pretty after what we
found people miss is that some of the
procedures that were interested in have
been done in 1950s 1960s 1970s but very
often those references are not
considered that far and when you need
those articles spray often they're not
in these databases that larger sitters
you subscribe to so you have to end up
paying for that so again it's just an
additional cost to think about when you
are thinking about bringing in a
surgical model in house all right so now
going back to the chart so we have the
next step is review I had summary of
references so for this we end up
utilizing surgeons I'm in here you know
you have the time a little bit under 90
hours at $62 per hour again this can
vary quite a bit depending on the you
know if you're in academia industry
where you are in a world but the
subtotal for that is 450 400 dollars so
the next step surgical protocol
development again for this we utilized
surgeons and the number of hours it's
14.9 so that ends up being a little bit
under a thousand dollars then facilities
review so this is where we work with the
technicians and the surgeons won't do a
walk-through and review what's available
for the facilities so that takes pretty
small amount of time but again
everything adds up so this is you would
have 111 over hundred dollars delivered
or three hundred dollars so four hundred
dollars together they will get the
supplies and equipment again this is
where the surgeon and research
technician is involved and all together
that's about six hundred dollars
for their time they were looking at the
animal selection so this is where the
scientists and the surgeon is involved
and they have a discussion we know like
we talked about what would be
appropriate model so that's a little bit
under three hundred dollars so then
performing a surgeon selection it's
little bit under two hundred dollars and
for that you have the surgeon
researchers are involved then we're
looking at the surgical procedure
piloting so this is where the surgeon
but ray technician or their research
technician is involved and that caused
us a little bit under a thousand dollars
so one of the things that's not
considered and discharged at a stable as
organizing and scheduling of the rooms
of the animals the procedures surgical
suite occupancy you know what's the
charge for that that varies quite a bit
by the institutions for surgical duties
so you know surgical suite cleaning
instrument cleaning and sterilization
looking at the disposable supplies and
new supplies they need to get animal
cost animal housing post-operative care
and nutrition which is very important
for able should differ for surgical Anna
paramus undergo surgery versus and
typical diets that you have and
providing to the animals when they're
not undergoing surgery so we're not
providing a cost for this because this
is going to vary quite a bit between
facilities and organizations but if you
are interested you can contact me after
the presentation and i'll be happy to
chat with you about those costs so you
know we talk about surgical procedure
piloting so the next one s
piloting or assessing then pilot
procedures so here we involve surgeons
and that's a little bit over a thousand
dollars then you have the surgical
protocol refinement so now looking at
the procedure those perform we sit down
and look at what are some of the
refinements that we could incorporate
into the protocol and you will see that
very often there's quite a few even
after all this whole process that we
looked at so then running a surgical
pilot study you're going to have the
surgeons of a trained technicians
involved research technicians and that's
about five thousand dollars so all
together for for this you're going to
end up with about sixteen thousand
dollars and this is over the time period
of time and number of procedures that we
have developed and obviously that would
vary a little bit but I think that gives
you little make a good idea or you know
what what's the cost that you would have
thinking about bringing a new procedure
in house so the timeline consideration I
think this is also very important bring
a new procedure in house is going to
take time it's not going to happen
overnight so what's the timeline that
the scientist has or the PhD student has
um you know is that for example you need
to test something a compound or a drug
that's already on the market and clinics
and you do additional studies or it's in
the final phase of the preclinical
trials so all those things are going to
play a huge role and it's really
important to consider that that a new
model is not going to come on board
within a week or two weeks it certainly
takes time to have an a model that works
appropriately so at that point you make
up your decision is it going to be
in-house or are we gonna outsource it so
again for the purposes of this
presentation
let's decide that we're going to do it
in-house so the next steps include
piloting of the surgical procedure so
this is where you can do one two or
three animals when the surgeon is
already obviously have selected the
surgeon and the procedure is video
recorded because that allows very
surgeons afterwards to review the video
and one assess to certain extent the
capabilities of the surgeon but more
importantly are there any refinements
that we could implement throughout the
procedure may be looking at a different
surgical instrumentation that's easier
to grasp something those are some of
that things to consider so after that do
you pilot that surgery then we're
looking at protocol refinement so again
that allowed us to assess the competency
of the surgeon that the proficiency
because it's such a small number of
animals that we use for profiling on the
test subject and also consider
post-operative care what's necessary did
we have everything that that's required
do we have all the staff that's
available you know does the post up get
have to be 24 hours or is it you know
you know short of your time what
everybody is there at the facility
looking at the environment where the
animals being recovered and again after
finding the surgery gives you a pretty
good idea do you have all the equipment
and supplies including the miscellaneous
supplies so what's really important that
you need to define success rate so again
through all of the references this whole
process that you have done need to
decide what is the success rate so is it
ninety-five percent of them surviving
for 20 weeks two weeks 40 weeks and then
again the number of animals that's
required so that's also very important
are you going to be doing if you have a
twenty percent mortality rate you might
need more animals for their procedure so
it's really important to identify the
number of animals required so here I
want to provide you with the validation
or a short study that we looked at where
we implemented our refined process for
bringing surgical procedures in house to
on the conventional way and that many
people bring in animal surgeries in
house and we have certainly done it in
the past as well so here we're looking
at a couple one yet the gastric bypass
in a rat that was done through
conventional process then we had gastric
bypass in a mouse and that was performed
with the refined process then we have
kidney transplant in a rat and that was
the font performed with the defined I am
sorry the refined process and then we
did brought in a kidney transplant in a
mouse and we use the conventional
process to bring that model in house so
here in this table you can see on the
left-hand side of the procedure on the
second column we provide a fairly
conventional or refined technique or the
process that we incorporated for it the
species and then which the important
columns are the mortality column so you
can see the from conventional way when
we implement it that way on mortality
was twenty-five percent when we did that
in a mouse with revive process it
dropped to five percent then for the
renal transplant in a rat way brought it
in with the refined processes on the
mortality was ten percent however when
we performed at the similar procedure
and
and mouse have brought that in-house
with that common the conventional way
that that the mortality rate was thirty
percent the other Hospital we looked at
his number of complications that
happened so that's the next column so
for the conventional rat gastric bypass
the number is 21 but then will we
utilize the refined processes for the
mouse for the same procedure the number
of complications was fine and when we
looked at the reader transplant with the
refined procedure with rats again the
number of complications was fine when we
brought in the renal transplant
technique and a mouse utilize a
convention technique the number of
complications was 22 and then the next
column we looked at the number of
refinements that we implement it so are
using a conventional technique and a rat
wind up implementing for the gastric
bypass 17 refinements the next one when
you look at the gastric bypass and the
mouse utilizing refined technique it's
only three and so the big difference
there is that a lot of the refinements
that we end up implementing and the
conventional technique after the
surgeries have already happened we
already have implemented those during
the process of developing the surgical
protocol and a refined process and you
can see on the bottom again the last two
for the refined foreigner transplant in
a rat the number of refinements was only
three when for that with the
conventional technique for the mouse it
was 14 so now just some statistics for
you to look at so this is the mortality
so on the left hand side you have
conventional and on the right hand side
you have the refined technique so with
the refined technique we found that it's
significantly different a lower
mortality percentage then we look at
complications again with the refined
process are we had significantly less
complications than with the conventional
process for refinements and we had
significantly less refinements with the
refined technique and then with the
conventional technique and again the
reason for that is that most of the
refinements were implemented during the
purple development before the surgeries
because of all the information that was
available to us so I think what's very
important that initially also as these
processes as we develop these processes
we ended up asking for 20 animals to be
allowed to have successful surgeries
because we found that with the
conventional processes various
complications happen afterwards and etc
now utilize the refining process we look
at that find animals for most of the
procedures have to be have to survive in
order out of 5 for us to move move
forward so this slide just summarizes
the steps that we already described that
are incorporated in the refined process
that we have implemented and same thing
with with this light again this is just
the steps that are required for this
process to work so at this point I will
take any questions or comments
suggestions and also for NHS if you like
to reach out to me after this
presentation or any time really here's
my email address so if we could describe
how to do the Q&A session again I would
greatly appreciate that
so julienne if you would be able to do
that that would be great thank you for
that informative presentation so before
we get started on question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you
could submit questions by typing them
into the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button on the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to answer as many questions as
we can our first question is from Paul
sign of so-called preclinical services
he says your charges are threatening to
the unknowing but they are based on
company chargebacks between internal
call centers such systems are archaic
instead of only product development when
cautious managers want to make an
impression with their bosses through
their cost savings it is much better for
companies to see animals facilities as
open shared research services where
everyone is on paid salary through
corporate and all costs for any
particular classes 0 rd is too important
for cautious middle managers to be
afraid of spending money so what are
your thoughts for conscious middle
managers to be so thank you so much for
that comment tonight we totally agree
with you on that the reason why I just
brought the cost is just that someone
that things to consider but I agree with
you and unfortunately or unfortunately
the systems are still in place and are
very often considered so until they go
away or we decide we all decide the rd
is more important and really not to as
you say stifle the moving forward you
know it's still something that we
have to think about and consider so the
next hi madalina phenyo of the institute
of cellular biology and pathology asked
to please give some refinement examples
so but I think
that question so the refinements very
significantly for some little things
like for example going from a 602 an
eight at suture or nine hunter and
different searching materials to
providing a different animal monitoring
equipment especially when it comes to
rodents depending for to put do int
allometry so again it can vary quite a
bit but disorder that the most common
once that they will utilize again at
this point our facility is pretty well
set up for that but throughout all of
these processes again instrumentation
and has been also a big one so a lot of
times we have found that utilizing
different instruments from the utilizing
neonate surgeries or even have surgical
instruments specifically developed for
specific procedures utilizing 3d
printing these days so there's a lot of
opportunities for that we have that
that's available to you but disorder is
just some of the examples so I hope that
answers your question and if it does not
please shoot me an email and i'll be
more than happy to provide you a slew of
examples that we have incorporated over
the last almost over a decade now i look
at
from Kanaan ministries asks how quickly
can tunic juice technicians be trained
for refined surgical models so so that's
an excellent question and it's a it's a
tough one as an example what if them so
I guess I just want to make sure I also
don't understand the question correctly
so if you if the person has performed
has been performing a procedure and now
you're looking to refine a procedure
that can happen if they're open-minded
pretty pretty quickly pretty rapidly I
mean again just incorporating some of
the things like assessment the video
atrophy of the procedure but if you're
talking about learning a new procedure
for a technician they can vary
significantly obviously with the
procedure one of the examples recently
those published than just learning the
correct suturing technique for
veterinary students it takes a poor the
surgeon's knot and square knot I believe
it's about two and a half hours just for
that and we well know that when we do
training workshops and in our field you
know we spend maybe a day or a couple
days training in these different
procedures we're here just for the basic
knots it took us two and a half hours to
be confident and proficient in that
technique so I hope that addresses the
question your question if it does not
please add another short comment in
there and I'll try to address it
if there are normal questions I would
like to once again thank dr. chiffon bar
on forest presentation do you have any
final comments what let's see that we
have a pretty full virtual room so I
kept writing my contact information and
i will be certainly very interested in
hearing your feedback you know how do
you develop again i said that the
conventional technique is very common
but maybe i'm wrong about that maybe
that has changed within last several
years so if you develop different models
that we have a process for it i would
love for you to get in touch with me and
discuss it again we're looking for any
input that we would allow us to improve
our techniques and then also of course
if you have any questions that can help
you out in any way during these
processes i'll be one happy to chat with
you again just reach out to me by email
and we can do it by email or at earth DC
but i would also like to thank lab roots
and forward opportunity to present this
content and also for running this event
for the fifth time and already have
scheduled next event for 2017 which is
also going to be very exciting and so
again look for dead informations coming
through you can actually i believe even
register for it now so you receive all
the reminder reminder sport and again
thank you to you for coming to the
session of a great facility can
available for on-demand viewing through
six months from the live date you will
receive an email from libraries alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward the
announcement to your colleagues who have
made who may have missed today's live
event see you next time and goodbye